now after four years in exile catalan's
ex-president carlos pujdemon has been
arrested in italy he led an independence
movement in spain's autonomous region of
catalonia eventually staging a vote to
succeed
that the spanish supreme court deemed
illegal
he fled and despite a couple of close
calls
managed to remain free
until now
has managed to elude madrid for years
but his luck may have just run out at an
airport on the italian island of
sardinia
puchdeman's lawyer gonzalo boy confirmed
the former catalan president's arrest
late on thursday night
saying pouch demon was arrested earlier
in the afternoon after being stopped by
italian border police spain accuses
pogdemorn of organizing an independence
referendum in catalonia in october of
2017.
the referendum declared illegal by
spain's central government threw the
country into its worst constitutional
crisis in decades
with the result pujdemon and other
catalan leaders declared independence
from madrid
spain responded by charging him and
other leaders with rebellion and
sedition
fled to belgium where he ran for
election in the 2019 european
parliamentary elections
he won a seat there and gained the
immunity from prosecution that comes
with being a member of european
parliament
but the european parliament rescinded
that immunity in march this year
that decision however is currently under
appeal
now with his arrest in italy pujdamon
faces being extradited back to spain
butchdemon's lawyer says he's expected
to appear in an italian court on
friday
and dw correspondent nicole reese joins
us now from madrid uh nicole how likely
is it that spain will want to get a hold
of pujman i mean nine other catalan
leaders as we've heard
were just pardoned
yes these pardons actually created a lot
of controversy in the country so you can
really feel that this is a hot button
issue here in spain the opposition party
leaders are demanding his extradition to
spain and also the supreme court has
said that they want to put an on trial
in the country so they're also demanding
his extradition
in the meantime the spanish government
though is keeping a rather lower profile
they issued a statement saying that they
will be okay with any decision the
italian authorities are taking and if
you look at it closer prime minister
pedro sanchez right now is in a very
very delicate position maybe even very
inconvenient because he has just started
talks with the catalan separatist
politicians to ease tensions to bring
both sides closer together he also
depends on them
for his government actually in 2019 he
was calling fresh elections because it
was exactly these politicians would not
support his budget drop so he's kind of
under pressure from various sides here
and that's probably also why at the
moment the government is keeping a
rather low profile on this and waits
what will happen so why was then putimon
arrested in sardinia in particular
well it is said that he was on his way
to a pro-independence event and he was
arrested on the basis of a european
arrest warrant now at the moment uh the
authorities in italy are trying to find
out if this warrant is actually valid
the judges of butcherman say that uh
this warrant has actually not been
finalized and confirmed so they have to
really look into this matter and let's
not forget a few years ago putin was
also
detained by german authorities and then
later released because the judges there
could not find any real reason to really
keep him
you mentioned the talks with the
government what is next for the
independence movement in catalonia
well the independence movement in
catalonia
is still quite active we've already seen
protesters outside the italian concert
in barcelona right now this morning in
favor of of putin on their protesting
and
it is very likely that if he is being
extradited although his importance has
has been less and less over the past few
years that there will be a huge wound
that will open up again this whole
tensions conflict between the spanish
central government and the region will
fire up again and um i think at that
time we could expect really huge
protests and this is actually actually
in a moment where the spanish government
is trying to uh keep things at ease and
at bay so very inconvenient actually for
them nicole reese in madrid thank you so
much